le premier salon de l'amour ouvrira ses
portes demain quai d'austerlitz à paris
un salon qui vient à point nommé quand
l'on sait que les divorces eux n'ont
cessé d'augmenter de façon régulière en
france au cours des 20 dernières années
la région parisienne enregistre des
records en la matière reportage de luc
fournier et philippe chasselas cette
image attendrissante sera aux archives
dans quelques années si la courbe des
divorces continue à s'élever on divorce
davantage en région parisienne qu'en
province
evelyne sullerot sociologue spécialiste
de la famille explique dans une grande
métropole comme paris ou la banlieue
autour
les gens ne se connaissent pas par
famille et donc quand ils se marient y
forma couple peut-être mais pas cette
alliance pas cette solidarité qui
justement fonde une famille comme dans
les communautés qui se connaissent ce
sont les femmes qui veulent divorcer il
ya 10 ans seulement
c'était 6 sur 10 des femmes maintenant
c'est les trois caves 1 75% des divorces
sont demandés par les femmes ou initiés
par les femmes
alors certaines enquêtes montrent que
beaucoup d'entre elles disent avoir un
mari alcoolique ou être battue je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse généraliser il ya
encore beaucoup de divorces par faute et
c'est surtout l'adultère à ce moment là
ma fidélité
ceux là sont demandés presque toujours
par les femmes les hommes étant beaucoup
plus volages le divorce par consentement
mutuel est en constante progression
depuis 1976 plus surprenant l'enfant
n'est plus un obstacle puisque les trois
quarts des couples divorcés sont parents
la séparation est encore facilitée par
l'indépendance financière des femmes
grâce à leur emploi on évoque aussi les
carrières ambitions différentes qui font
prendre au couple un chemins divergents